حياكم الله في بودكاست السوق من ثمانيه في
حلقتنا اليوم راح نتكلم عن الهوس الجديد
بالانتاجيه وكيف انه بعض الناس وصلوا
مراحل متقدمه في متابعه هذا الهوس وحدهم
وظف ناس توقف وراه عشان تشوفه وهو قاعد
يشتغل من غير ما يلتهي باشياء ما لها دخل
في شغله الرئيسي بعدها راح ننتقل ونتكلم
عن استحواذين تموا في المنظومه عندنا في
الاسبوع الماضي استحواذ من شركه اي ان
شركه اتصالات الاماراتيه على شركه
وايضا استحواذ من
السعودي هلا على شركه
الاماراتيه راح نناقش الاستحواذين
وابعادهم ودور شركات الاتصالات في تنميه
المنظومه الرقميه والرياديه في المنطقه
بعدها راح ننتقل للحديث عن
طريقه جديده في وصندوق جديد صندوق تنامي
واللي مو اول شركه
عن طريق ما يعرف
راح نناقش هذه الطريقه الجديده راح نتكلم
عن فوائدها وعيوبها واهميه وجود صندوق مثل
هذا في المنطقه بعدها راح نتكلم على صندوق
واللي قدر انه ياخذ 27 مليون دولار
لصندوقهم الجديد من بنك الاستثمار
الاوروبي في انجاز جديد
للصناديق والمنظومه المحليه بعدها راح
نتكلم على جوله طراز الف لشركه تلقاني
لتاجير السيارات بقيمه 6 مليون دولار
واخيرا نتكلم عن اير بي ام بي واول سنه في
تاريخ الشركه تنتقل للربحيه حققت في عام
1.9 مليار دولار من الارباح في سابقه غير
معهوده وايش معنى هذا الشيء وش دليله على
شركات محليه مثل
في كل مره اذكركم انكم تشاركون هذه الحلقه
مع اي شخص يعتقدون انه مهتم في هذا النوع
من المحتوى استمتعوا
[موسيقى]
ودي اتكلم عن واحد من اهم امراض العصر
الحديث اللي حنا فيه واللي هو موضوع
الانتاجيه يعني انا كنت اتوقع اني حريص
على الانتاجيه يوم اني قبل يمكن ثلاث
سنوات قفلت كل الاشعارات في جوالي وفخور
جدا بهذا الانجاز الغير مسبوق وفعلا
ساعدني في زياده انتاجيتي لكن كل احلامي
بالانتاجيه انتهت لما سمعت عن خوينا
المدون اللي
وظف احد يعطيك كف كل مره ينشغل عن المهمه
اللي هو قاعد يشتغل فيها بس ليته وقف هنا
لا قرر يسوي شيء جديد ووظف ثلاث اشخاص
يجلسون وراءه في المكتب
ويراقبون وايش قاعد يسوي او يدفع لهم
بالساعه واذا
انشغل مثلا فتح فيسبوك ولا تويتر ولا اي
شيء نبهوه وهوشوه وجرب هالتجربه على مدى
شهر ودفع لهم تقريبا عشره الاف دولار بس
على اساس انه يقدر يرفع من انتاجيته
وبزعمه انه قدر يضاعف انتاجيته ثلاث مرات
في الشهر هذا
[موسيقى]
هذه ايضا يعني من الاشياء المحفزه
الانتاجيه لان الجميع قاعد يتفرج عليك
ويشوف ايش قاعد تسوي تحط نفسك تحت الرول
لكن يعني شوفوا هم قديم يعني اهم من ايام
اليونانيين والاغريق على اسطوره اللي
يحاول يعبر البحر ويحذروه من حوريات البحر
اللي اسمه مسايرنس وكانوا معروفات حسب
ملحمه
المعروفه انهم يغبون البحاره على اساس
يقربون من منهم بسبب صوتهم وبعدين يسقعون
بالصخور وتغرق السفن في كل مره
بطل القصه هذه عاد قال لا انا ابغى اسمع
صوتهم لكن وابغى اكمل رحلتي بشكل انتاجي
ما اموت فطلب من البحاره اللي معاه انه
يربطونه بعمود السفينه
ويحطون صمغ على اذانهم وبالتالي قدر يسمع
صوت الحوريات وبدون ما يخرب جدوله وتخرب
انتجيته الرحله وكما طريقه بسلام بس يعني
انا اشوف صراحه انا قلت يمكن مرض من امراض
العصر الحديث لان اشوف في نوع من اختزال
الانسان اليوم لفكره الانتاجيه بشكل عام
وكانه هو يعني موجود فقط لكي يكون منتج
فصحيح انه ذكرنا امثله شاطحه مثل خوينا
المدون هذا لكن اليوم اغلب نصائح الصحيه
والغذائيه كلها
تثبت فعاليه برامجها ويعني جدوها فقط اذا
اصبحت منتج اكثر بمعنى لو خذيت لك نظام
غذائي يقول لك والله قدرت اركز اكثر لان
هذا الاكل يحسن من مستوى التركيز عندي
وغيرها من الاشياء يعني يبدو انه صار فيه
هوس ما هو بطبيعي وغير مسبوق يعني ما اذكر
يمكن قبل 30 40 سنه ما اعتقد ان كان هذا
هو محور يعني اهتمام كثير من الناس اليوم
هو المحور الرئيسي كل احد يبغى يركز اكثر
يبغى ينتج اكثر بيكون فعال اكثر
وما ادري اذا هذا الشيء الصحي ولا لا لانه
لما تفكر فيها يعني حتى لما
يدرس طريقه التفكير الادمي عند النظامين
نظام الاول الواعي ونظام غير الواعي
احيانا تبغى تعطي العفويه فرصه تبي تعطي
سرندبيه فرصه واذكر زميلنا في الصندوق
مارفل دائما يقول يعني
فاشتغل زي العسل يجيك فتره معينه تخلص صعب
تقول لا لا هو البدايه وكذا بطريقه
انا معك انا معك
لكن الفكره انه هذه لاحظنا يعني في مثلا
على الاقل في مجالي لما كنت مهندس انه
تجيك فترات انتاجيتك جدا عاليه على الذروه
وتخلص حل المشكله وبعدين يجيك فتره خلاص
مخك ما يقدر يكمل تبي ترتاح انت لا تقدر
انك ترتاح لكن فعليا مخك قاعد يسوي شيء
ثاني وانت ما تدري يساعد في قاعد يفكر
بعمق اكثر قاعد يفكر بزوايه اخرى قاعد
يرسخ دروس اللي استفت منها فانت تبي
تعطيها نظامين اللي داخل فرصه ايضا انهم
يعني كل واحد ياخذ دوره معاد انا اتوقع
سبب من اسباب الهوس الزياده الحين
الشيء الاول المنافسه زادت كل واحد بيسبق
على وش الترند ولا شيء الموضوع
اللي شغالين عليه لكن هذا اتوقع زيادته
كانت اقل من الزياده الاخرى اللي هي
الخيارات الاشياء اللي ممكن تلهيك عن
الشغل اللي معك طول الوقت يعني اول كانت
تستنى تخلص دوامك عشان تروح تشوف العائله
والاصدقاء ولا تطلع تسوي نشاط ثاني الحين
جات معك السوشيال ميديا وغيره في جوادك
فزياده المنافسه زياده الاشياء اللي ممكن
تاخذ من انتاجيتك اتوقع في ناس قالوا يعني
خلاص يعني كيف نفوز على الاثنين في نفس
الوقت لو تذكرون كان في كمان بعض امثله
سيليكون بالي كانوا يقولون نصوم ثلاث ايام
يزيد معدل الكيتوسس في الجسم وما ادري ايش
بعدين تقعد لك تسوي يسمونها البنج يقعدون
يوم يوم ونص يومين كامله بس البرمجه وعلى
طاري زي ما قلت ابو عبد العزيز الاسد
المطور هذا يخلص مشكله كبيره في يوم ونص
يومين ويقدر يرتاح بعده يعني تذكرون قصه
انفجرت في عالم الكريبتو واكتشفوا كيف كان
سام يجبر الموظفين يعني
يفرض عليهم بشكل او باخر انهم ياخذون
المحسنات التركيز عشان يصيرون بشكل اكبر
فالوضع فعلا يعني يخليك تفكر وين وين
الطيف شفنا عالم العمل عن بعد ايام
الجائحه وكيف استغلوا الناس انه الانتاجيه
اللي موجوده في الشركات الكبيره قليله جدا
لدرجه انه واحد من الناس اللي جربوا هذا
الشيء يقدر ياخذ اكثر من الوظيفه وحسب ما
قريت وصل الى ثمان وظائف كلها عن بعد
وشركات يشتغل فيها ما يدري انه جات ياخذه
وظائف هذي كلها كلهم وبعدين
يعني
شغاله رجال مبسوط وقادر يعني يكمل حياته
بشكل عادي حسب زعمه فالموضوع انتاجيه يعني
موضوع احياء جزء منه مسرح جزء منه
ابغى ارسل رساله للاخرين واقول لهم ترى
انا منتج وجزما انه يمكن احيانا محاوله
فعلا الواحد انه يقول لا انا ابغى انافس
منافسه جدا عاليه يعني انا بس كنت اذكر
يعني موضوع الشركات نفسهم لما نتكلم عن
انه السنه هذه سنه كفاءه شفنا
بيت طلعوا قالوا الجميع الان يرددها
الانتاجيه حسب عدد الموظفين هذا واحد من
المؤشرات يعني
للشركات وقدرتها انها ترفع الانتاجيه انا
حاولت كذا اشوفها القطاع واحد لفتاه نظري
امازون امازون عندهم مليون ونصف موظف
تقريبا لكن معدل الايرادات على الموظف
الواحد تجاوزه 324 الف دولار
يعني فكر لو تشوف الشركات الصغيره بعضها
ما يجون ولا عشر المبلغ هذا فالانتاجيه
فيها اكيد زاويه بس احيانا تتلخبطوا مع
الضوضاء اللي قاعده تصير ونشوف اشياء اخرى
ما تساعد الانتاجيه الحقيقيه طبعا هذا
وامازون يعني اكثر شغلهم
يعني اوف لاين فبالتالي دائما الشركات
الاون لاين هي يكون عندها
دخل لكل موظف عالم كثير من الشركات الاوف
لاين فهذه اشاده لكفاءتهم لكن ذكرتني عبد
الله سالفه المشتتات فعلا يعني اليوم
سالفه التنبيهات بس حقت الجوال سواء كنت
مبرمج ولا ايا تكن يعني انت قاعد تحاول
تنجز مهمه معينه
وفجاه جوالك هو قاعد يزاحمك يعني اذا عندك
تنبيهات من واتساب ولا من الشبكات
الاجتماعيه وغيرها فانا اشوف هذا فعلا
يعني
هذه مشكله كبيره لدرجه اذكر احد زملائي في
كريم سابقا كان يقول لي انتم يا الملينيوز
اللي هم اللي مولودين نهايه الثمانينات
الى منتصف التسعينات يقول انا اعرفكم مجرد
ما ادخل المكتب دائما احب اناظر واشوف
يعني كان يتكلم عن دور كان في مبرمجين
يمكن حول 400 مبرمج يقول
تلقاهم جالس يشتغل على اللابتوب والجوال
يعني قدامه بطريقه يقدر يشوفها باستمرار
يقول انتم عندكم مرض ما هو بطبيعي كيف
انكم مدمنين على تنبيهات هذه تبون تعرفون
كل شيء قاعد يصير بينما اللي اكبر منكم
شويه يعني الى حد ما يعانون من هذا المرض
فيعني تحدي كبير صراحه الايام هذه كيف انك
ما تنشغل بشيء انت ما نويت انك تنشغل فيه
واللي هو يعني التنبيهات على على يعني
التطبيقات التجاريه للخوف هذا اللي موجود
عندنا والحرصه الانتاجيه في في سوقين
طلعوا الفتره الاخيره في سوق اسمه
رفع العزيمه او الالتزام سواء رفع
الانتاجيه او انك يعني تاخذ عاده معينه
وتصير طبع عندك
في ناس طلعوا قواعد بيانات كل انواع
الاجهزه مثلا تبغى تقوم بدري في ساعه تنقز
كذا بالصباح وتقدر تلاحقها غصبا عليك
عليها كفرات في اجهزه سوف مثلا تحط التزام
اللي انت تبغاه تبغى تلتزم بهدف معين
وخلاص ياخذ عليك تعهد اذا ما حققته خلال
فتره معينه راح يضيع فشلك لشبكه معينه من
الناس فبالتالي العزيز
تطبيق المنبه اذكر كان صديقي يستخدمه في
الجامعه اللي اذا رن المنبه ما يطفى لما
تحل مساله رياضيه
وعشان تسوي سنوز وكل ما تسوي سنوز تصعب
المعادله تصعب المساله في النهايه ما تقدر
تطفيه
فهذا يعني خلينا نقول جزء كذا مثيل اهتمام
من المنتجات وفي جزء ثاني اللي يمكن اكثر
خطوره شوي لكن في اقبال كبير عليه في
السوق الامريكي اللي يسمونها فئه العقاقير
النوترون النترونكس لا نوترابيكس ويمكن
اكثر من الناس اللي يتكلمون فيها تمفيروس
اللي يطلع كتاب اسبوع اربع ساعات على اساس
يرفع الانتاجيه وتشوف فيه تجارب كثيره في
الحقل هذا بعضها نتائج يعني مثير اهتمام
لكن الاثار طويله المدى هذه اللي عليها
اعلام استفهام كبيره طيب ودي صراحه نتكلم
عن
استحواذين يعني صاروا الاسبوع هذا عندنا
كان استحواذ من شركه اتصالات اند اي اند
الاماراتيه سابقا معروفه بشركه اتصالات
وايضا كان عندنا استحواذ من ستار سعودي
هاله لكن خلونا نتكلم عن اتصالات اولا
استحوذوا على شركه سيرفس ماركت واللي هي
مختصه بالخدمات المنزليه يمكن عندنا في
السعوديه شركه مهاره والعديد من الشركات
المشابهه لها
واللطيف انه مو باول استحواذ في هذا
القطاع يعني لو تذكرون قبل كم حلقه تكلمنا
عن استحواذ على شركه رزق ايضا في الامارات
في نفس المجال تقريبا
وطبعا شركه اي اند صراحه تحركاتها الاخيره
مثيره جدا للاهتمام يعني شفنا لو تذكرون
قبل ست شهور تقريبا او حتى اربع شهور
استحوذوا على حصه اغلبيه في شركه ستارز
بلاي
وقبل هذا استحوذوا على شركه
المقاضي فواضح انه ما شاء الله عليهم
قاعدين يعني يتوسعون في تنويع خدماتهم
للمستخدمين اللي عندهم وايضا اعلنوا عن
صندوق استثمار الراسمالي جريء قبل فتره
وكان نشط في العديد من الصفقات وذكرني هذا
الخبر ايضا اعلان اس تي سي الاسبوع الماضي
اللي تكلمنا عنه عن صندوقهم الجديد والدور
المهم اللي تلعبه فعلا شركات الاتصالات
يعني على مستوى السعوديه على سبيل المثال
اس تي سي كانت من الشركات اللي اول من اسس
واحد من اكبر الصناديق اللي هو اس تي سي
فانتشرز وبعدين اس تي سي كان المستثمر
الرئيسي والوحيد في اكبر صندوق في المنطقه
الى اليوم هذا صندوق خاص اللي هو اس تي في
ب 500 مليون دولار وبعدين اسسوا الان
صندوق يعني جديد ايضا كان عندهم مسرعه ادت
اداء حسن وكان لها اثر ايجابي في المنطقه
اللي هي انسباريو فيعني شركات الاتصالات
بشكل عام ترى محرك مهم لسوق الرياده غير
انها يعني تملك الاموال الا انها تملك
قاعده كبيره جدا من العملاء واللي تقدر من
خلالها تسوق منتجات الشركات عليهم ومستحيل
انسى يعني
فضل كبير لاس تي سي على كريم يعني اتذكر
في فتره من الفترات كان 15% من الدخل الحق
كريم هو عباره عن صرف عملاء اس تي سي
لنقاط قطاف على المنصه
رقم مخيف جدا غير انه طبعا يعتبر صرف غير
كاش لانه وقتها كان معدلات استخدام
البطاقات منخفض جدا الا انه يظل هذا يعتبر
بالنسبه للشركه مساحه للنمو مبنيه على
مكافات جيتهم من شركه الاتصالات وهي علاقه
تكامليه يعني شركات اتصالات سواء بالمنطقه
او في العالم هم فعليا البنيه التحتيه
الاقتصاد الرقمي لكن هذه فيها مزايا وعيوب
المزايا واضحه لكن واحده من العيوب انه
هوامش الربحيه هذه كلها قاعده تطلع للطبقه
اللي فوق الى شركات البرمجيات والشركات
الرقميه فبالتالي صار في منصه محترقه يعني
حسب المصطلح الاستراتيجي هنا للشركات
الاتصال يتحركون ويستعدون نوع نوع
القيمه اللي قاعدين يضيفونه للسوق واذا ما
تحركوا وبعدين بيصيرون فقط ماسوره
للبيانات زيهم زي شركه المويه شركه الغاز
وغيرهم فبالتالي هي فرصه ذهبيه بالنسبه
لشركه اتصالات وعندهم مزايا للتفوق فيها
وايضا ما عندهم اي خيار اخر الا انهم
ينغمسون اكثر في الاقتصاد الرقمي
ويستخدمون المزايا الموجوده عندهم
لينتقلون يستمرون
كشركات ذات هوامش ربحيه عاليه مو زيهم او
الشركات اللي موجوده في البنيه التحتيه
الاخرى هذه النقطه ابو عبد العزيز بعض
الناس لما نتناقش معهم يشوفونها بعيده
ويعني بعد نشوف متى تسير يصيرون شركات
خدمات لكن بس يبغى لك تتذكر الهاتف الثابت
والجوال يعني الان كم نسبه الناس اللي
يبغون يسوون او عدد الناس اللي يبغون
يركبون خطوط هاتف ارضيه جديده
وكمل يستخدمون كم يدفعون شركه الاتصالات
يعني كم نسبه حتى ايراد شركات الاتصالات
من هذه النوع من الهواتف مقارنه بالجوال
او البيانات اكثر تحديدا كذلك فالانتقال
مهم
لكن السؤال لانه بالنسبه الاتصالات
استثماراتها مثيره للاهتمام في المنطقه
وفي الدول العالم لكن وش هو اعاده التعريف
للشركه نفسها يعني هل هي شركه خدمات زائد
استثمارات اخرى متنوعه ولا حلهم بيشوفون
قيمه مضافه مستدامه هم يقعدون يقدمونها
للمستخدمين يعني انا ما عندي اجابه واضحه
لكن هذا الشيء اللي دائما يدور في بالي هل
تصير منصه محتوى مثلا ستارز بلاي او غيرها
ما تصور بيكون كافي لكن وش نموذج العمل
الجديد بالاضافه طبعا لتقديم الخدمات يعني
يعني اللي يبدو لي صراحه من استراتيجيه اي
اند ان توجههم هو هو الان يملك العميل
سواء اللي عنده منه خدمه الانترنت المنزلي
وخدمه الجوال التحدي هو كيف اقدر اكبر
التذكره انا ما اقدر ارفع سعر باقات
الانترنت بالعكس قاعده تقل الوقت ولا اقدر
ارفع سعر باقات الجوال لانها ايضا قاعد
اشغل ومدى اهميه الجوال قاعد يقيم يقلك
كباقه اتصال
فاعتقد البعد الاستراتيجي عندهم انه كيف
انا اقدر مع الوقت وطبعا ما اقدر استحود
على عمله جدد لانه السوق هذا يعني
متقطع خلاص يعني هذا الشركه عندها حصتها
وانا عندي حصتي طبعا في مساحه للعب بالحصص
لكنها مكلفه ومستوى تحرك الحصص يعني بطيء
ما تقدر فجاه تغير حصتك بشكل دراماتيكي
فلابد اني انا اشوف طريقه ازود يعني صرف
العميل معي يعني على سبيل المثال اذكر لما
اشتركت في باقه الانترنت كان في باقه
معاها تلفزيون وباقه فوقها ستارز بلاي
وباقه فوقها امازون برايم وفوقها نتفليكس
وما اعرف ايش فمحاوله انك تكبر
حجم التذكره من خلال اضافه خدمات اضافيه
ممكن حتى العميل ما لكن يشعر انه يحتاجها
وفي بعض الاحيان طبعا ممكن انه تكون فعلا
مفيده وهذا اعتقد يعني
الحل المثالي انك انت فعلا تقدم خدمات
يحتاجونها عملائك على هل منوال يعني اللي
انا فهمته من الخبر انه اي اند راح تدمج
الشركه المستحوذ عليها داخل منصه سمايل
الخاصه فيها ولو نطالع باقي السوق نشوف
انه ترى في تحرك على مختلف القطاعات في
بعضها ايضا شركه او قطاع الاتصالات زي زين
مع منصه تمام للاقراض وشفنا يعني بروز قوي
لها الفتره الاخيره شفنا مؤخرا اعلان من
البنك المركزي لترخيص جهه تمويل الاسماء
فيول وهذه طالعه من بترومين ايضا شفنا
مدار الشركه اللوجيسيات بين العبيكان وعلم
وشفنا الركاب اللي راح الليف يمكن شاف
سياراتهم اللي هي تبع او طالعه من
سابكو
فاغلب الشركات الان بد ات تكتشف انه لازم
يعني تلقى مكان لها من الاعراب في
الاقتصاد الرسمي ونشوف تجارب مختلفه لهم
في اماكن مختلفه سواء كانت لوجستيات تنقل
ماليه خدميه وغيرها فاتوقع سنتين الجايه
بنشوف تجارب كثيره محليه من الشركات
الكبيره
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
طبعا اغلب الامثله اللي ذكرتها
يعني دائما تكون مصحوبه
باستوديوهات الشركات او البنشر على سبيل
المثال ركاب كمثال
ويبدو انه هذا النوع من الخدمات يعني ايضا
رائج الفتره الاخيره كثير من هذه الشركات
زي ما تفضلت عندهم هذا الفهم انه يحتاجون
يشوفون موقعهم من الاعراب وفي الاستديوهات
هذه اللي صارت متخصصه بتقديم الخدمات هذه
للشركات
فهذا السوق ايضا يعني قاعد يكبر وفي اقبال
عليه
ويبقى طبعا دائما السؤال هو هل فعلا تقدر
هذه الشركات انها تبني منصات
يعني مستدامه وتقدر تنمو وتصل يعني
مستوى عالي او كبير من الشعبيه عند الناس
هذا التساؤل اللي دائما اطرحه امام هذه
الفرص
اعتقد فصل هذه الشركات او يعني نماذج
العمل بشركات مستقله على الاقل محاوله من
الشركات الام انك تعطيها الفرصه للنجاح
بدل ما تسير اداره من ادارات الشركه الام
ومهما كان ما حتكون كبيره
الكفايه انها تاخذ الوقت او سرعه اتخاذ
القرار المطلوبه لكن زي ما قلت معاد الوقت
والمنافسه هي اللي بتحدد في الاخير عاد
انا اشوف يعني السؤال هنا هو هل هذه
الشركات اجدر بها انها
تستحوذ على شركات قائمه ممكن يكون عندها
بعض التحديات ويصير في نوع من التكامل
بينهم وبين الشركه الرياديه مثل ما قاعد
تسوي مثلا اي اند يعني سواء استحواذ على
ستارز ولا على الجروسر ولا يعني هذه
الشركات ما كانت خلينا نقول انها مكسره
الدنيا لكن عندها طاقه كامله ممكن توصل
وقدره شركه مثل اي اند انها توصلهم لشريحه
كبيره من العملاء من خلال شبكات التوزيع
اللي عندهم بلا شك راح تزيد فرص نجاحهم
وراح تعظم من حجم العوائد حقتهم يعني هذا
مسار ومسار اني انا اروح وادور فريق
تاسيسي
واقعد استثمر من الصفر وابني تقنيه من
الصفر واتعلم واندق عشرين ثلاثين مره يعني
انا اشوف انه مسار الاستحواذ خصوصا الفتره
هذه لسببين يعني اول شيء عندنا
من يعني في اخر ست سبع سنوات صار عندنا
مئات الستار اللي موجوده في المنطقه وهذا
الشيء ما كان موجود اول بالاضافه الى انه
اليوم بالذات يعني الاسعار خلينا نقول
بسبب كل
الاثار الصايره في سوق راس مال الجريء
اسعار الشركات هذه تعتبر
يعني في مرحله مغريه نسبيا والكثير ممكن
يكون
متطلع للتخارج وان لم يكن بمبالغ يعني
غير مسبوقه مثل ما الكثير يتمنى في
الاحوال المثاليه معاذ اعتقد نقطتك مهمه
تقدر نقطه مهمه كيف الشركات الكبيره بتفكر
السنه هذه والسنه الجايه لانه في كثير من
الاحيان ممكن يشوفون نموذج عمل ويقولون ما
في مشكله الفكره جيده وممكن نستثمر بس ليش
ادفع البريميوم ليش ادفع الزياده هذه اذا
تكلفه الاستبدال حقها انا اقدر اسويه
بنفسي لكن السنه هذه والسنه الجايه
اعتقد هذه الفاره
هم كلهم يقولون نقدر نسوي لانه
مشروع اذا كان الحل اذا كان الحل تقني
اعتقد لا ويكون وهم لكن اذا كان الحل اوف
لاين على سبيل الركاب زي ما ذكر ابو عبد
العزيز كمثال اعتقد يعني مقارنه عادله او
التساؤل عادل في هذه الحال يعني اكثر من
ضبط موضوع الاستحواذ والنمو من خلال
الاستحواذ هم طبعا شركات التقنيه يعني
تخيل
ابل لو ما استحوذات على
السري او تخيل جوجل بدون يوتيوب او تخيل
فيسبوك بدون واتساب كلها استحواذات ساعدت
في نمو الضخم اللي صار للشركات هذه لكن
بالمقابل ايضا مره صعب يعني لما تطالع نسب
نجاح الاستحواذات بعد ما يتم الاستحواذ
يعني كيف تربطهم كيف تشبكهم باقي الماكينه
الكبيره هذه عمليه بغايه الصعوبه لانه في
جزء كبير منها ثقافي جزء كبير منها
منافسه داخليه وسياسه داخليه واحده من
الامثله يعني اللي مشهوره مؤخرا اللي صار
في فيسبوك لما شروا شركه تي بي اتش اللي
خاصه بالشبكات اجتماعيه اللي بدون اسم
قتلوها طلع المؤسس وسوى شركه ثانيه اسمها
قاس
والان اشتريتها ديسكورد نفس الشركه بس
اللهم يعني هذيك قتلتها فيسبوك وراح سواها
من جديد بعد ما طلع من فيسبوك ونجحت
الديسكورد يمكن الشركات اللي تبغى تدخل
المجال هذا يبغى لهم يضبطون مهاره اللي
يسمونه او التطوير المؤسساتي لانه هذه
العمليه هي الجزئيه الصعبه فعلا في
الموضوع وبدونها احتماليه الفشل دائما
عليها طيب ودي نتكلم عن الاستحواذ الثاني
اللي صار الاسبوع هذا واللي هو استحواذ
شركه هلا السعوديه على شركه بهيمنت
الاماراتيه طبعا هلا للي ما يعرفها ولانه
هي متخصصه في خدمه المنشات الصغيره
والمتوسطه فقد لا تكون معروفه لكن هي من
الشركات اللي اعتقد سيكون لها اسم
في السنوات القادمه بحكم تطور الملحوظ
اللي قاعدين يعني يشهدون في هذا القطاع
واللي يعرفها يمكن يعرفها باسمها السابق
كانت كان اسمها هلله اطلقت عام 2016 كاوله
احد
المحافظ الكير
واليت حتى قبل محفظه اس تي سي بي لكن
لاسباب مختلفه لم تنجح معهم يعني فكره
المحفظه وتوجهوا لفكره خدمه
المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه على مستوى
المدفوعات والحسابات البنكيه وغيرها من
الخدمات اللي قاعدين يتوسعون فيها استحواذ
غير معلن كل الاستحواذ كانوا غير معلنين
لكن يعني
على قولك ابو عبد العزيز يعني هذه الشركه
تقنيه قاعده تستحوذ بينما البنوك والناس
الكبيره يعني يمكن قاعدين من المنصاتهم
بانفسهم يعطيهم العافيه
ومو باستحواذ هم الاول هلا استحوذوا على
فراش شركه فريش في عام 2021
وربطوا خدمات اللي كانت تقدمها
الخدمات الان تقدمها لعملائها كانت خدمات
غير ماليه
شركه المدفوعات الاماراتيه اللي استشهدوا
عليها الان واضح انها بتعبي جزء من
الخدمات اللي ما كانت موجوده من هلا اللي
هي طبيعه الحال المدفوعات في هذه الحاله
فتصير محفظه اداره مبيعاتك متابعه الارقام
وكذلك تقدر تمشي خدمه المدفوعات من خلال
نفس المنصه فاعتقد التكامل اللي قاعد
تسويه في الخدمات اللي تقدم لشركات
الصغيره المتوسطه بيخليها خيار اهم وافضل
لهذه الشركات كذا اخذت الناس بس كان في
ملاحظه من ماغنت انه
كل الاستحوذات اللي تمت هذه السنه طبعا
احنا ما كملنا شهرين
صايره في الامارات فكانت ملاحظه كذا مثال
اهتمام في نشاط جميل لكن صراحه يعني نرجع
شوي لهاله
نتكلم عن حسب يعني تصريحهم
حجم العمليات التي تمر من خلالهم او
المدفوعات التي تمر من خلالهم وصلوا الى
ثلاثه مليار دولار
سنويا رقم ابدا ابدا ما هو بسهل يعني
نتكلم على رقم قد يكون الاعلى يعني بين
الشركات اللي يعني في العمر هذا لانه
فعليا الخدمه حقتهم اطلقت عام 2020 بعد ما
سوى عمليه تحور من المحفظه
الى خدمه المنشات طبعا هاله يعني تكلمت مع
عصام النهدي الرئيس التنفيذي المؤسس
ودائما هو يتكلم
وياكد على انه هدف هذا هو ان يكون بنك
المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه في المنطقه حتى
وليس في السعوديه لما سالته ليش استحوذته
على بيمنت كان يقول لسببين رئيسيين السبب
الاول
شفنا فريق ممتاز ونبغى نستحوذ على المنتج
اللي بنوه لانه المنتج يكمل خططنا
الاستراتيجيه طبعا هي عباره عن
بوابه مدفوعات وعندهم خصائص اضافيه يعني
البوابات المعتاده مثل خاصيه ارسال
الروابط يعني ارسل لك رابط وتقدر تدفع من
خلال الرابط مثل ما يفاتوره وغيرهم فهذا
كان جزء تكميلي لكن اثار نقطه صراحه جدا
جدا مهمه برايي ودي يمكن نتكلم عنها شوي
يقول احنا من زمان نبغى نتوسع خارج
المملكه
وشفنا انه هذا الفريق عنده القدره على انه
ياخذ خدمات هلا نفسها ويوسعها خارج
المملكه وهنا نقطه صراحه تستحق التوقف
يعني
نادرا نادرا ما نلقى شركات فعلا قادره
انها تتوسع من دوله الى دوله سواء من مصر
للسعوديه او من السعوديه لمصر او ل او من
الامارات الى السعوديه يعني هذا الهاجس
الكبير اليوم عند كل الشركات كيف اني انا
اتوسع من دوله الى اخرى بغض النظر عن
الدوله اللي بدات فيها ونشوف دائما في
محاوله للشركات هذه انهم يبغون يوظفون
مدير عام في الدوله هذه او في المنطقه هذه
لكن لما اشوف انا دائما قصص النجاح
لشركات فعلا قدرت انها تتوسع بشكل اسطوري
وجبار وتستحوذ على حصه ممتازه من السوق
دائما اشوف اما عمليات استحواذ او حتى
عمليات يعني استحواذ على شريك مؤسس وكثير
من الناس عندهم حساسيه من هذا الشيء يعني
على سبيل المثال كريم لما دخلت السعوديه
استحوذت على شركه عنواني لعبد الله الياس
وانضم لهم كشريك مؤسس وصار هو الشركه
المؤسسه الثالث كنت اسمع لقاء عبد العزيز
اللغاني يتكلم عن بدايات طلبات وكان يقول
كيف انهم خسروا في طلبات السوق السعودي
وفعلا اليوم طلبات ما هو موجود في
السعوديه مع انه هو اول تطبيق
للمطاعم في المنطقه
خسروا السوق السعودي انا ما كان عندهم
الشريك المحلي الصحيح وعلى النقيض كان
يقول انهم في فلور قدروا يكسبوا السوق
السعودي لانهم استقطبوا شريك محلي ممتاز
مثل محمد العريفي فبس انا احب انا اعجبتني
هذه اللفته من من عصام ان ان مره مهم انك
تاخذ الشريك المحلي الصحيح وان كان هذا
الشيء مكلف مكلف من خلال الاستحواذ مادي
او اسهم او حتى من خلال انك تاخذ شريك
مؤسس يعني انا انصدم بعض المؤسسين لما
نقابلهم يقول لو سمحت ابغاك تساعدني احصل
مدير للسعوديه ولا مدير لاي دوله اخرى طيب
ليه ما تدخل معك شركه مؤسس لا لا لا احنا
ما نحتاج شريك مؤسس احنا امورنا طيبه طيب
اذا امورك طيبه روح ادخل السوق يعني مو
معقول انك انت تترك سوق مهم
احيانا لاجل حواجز يعني عقليه ليس لها
يعني من سلطان صراحه يعني هذه يذكرني
مقوله يعني لا تخاف على حصتك من الكيكه
كبر الكيكه
وجميع كسبان لكن اذا انت تعتقد ان الكيكه
يعني هذه هي ما راح تكبر ابدا دائما بتكون
مشلول بهالتفكير وما تقدر تتوسع فعلا ولا
تقدر تكسب الناس اللي فعلا انت تحتاجهم
يمكن ننتقل من الاستحواذات الى الجولات
ويمكن في طريقه جديده شفناها للتمويل في
المنطقه شركه يوغا جفت
حصلت على هديه ترجمه
اسمه نفسه حصلت على تمويل مرتبط
بالايرادات من شركه تنامي كابيتال 3 مليون
دولار هدفها الاساسي للتوسع في السعوديه
الطريقه ما هي براس مال ولاهي راس مالجري
ولا هيبدين جري بالع نتكلم عليها في
الجولات لكن هي تمويل مرتبط بالايراد او
بالايرادات يعني يعطونك تمويل ويتفقون على
نسبه من الايرادات
تدفعها لهم الى ما تصل لي غالبا مضاعف
معين من اللي اعطوك اياه ففي هذه الحاله
ثلاثه مليون دولار ما على نوع التفاصيل
لكن ياخذون نسبه من الايرادات الى على
سبيل المثال سته مليون دولار ولا تسعه
مليون دولار ضعفين او ثلاثه اضعاف
يعني طريقه جديده شركه لكن في مرحله مبكره
بس يمكن قالوا ما نبغى التقييمات الحاليه
ما نبغى راس مال جريء لها مزايا لها عيوب
ودي اسمع رايكم بهذا الطريقه للتمويل انا
كاني اشوف كيفن اوليري حق شوك تانك جالس
في الزاويه ومستانس ويضحك لانه هذا النوع
من التمويل ههه بس هو ياكل ياخذ معك يحط
يعطيك وترجع له وياخذ كم بالمئه
من الشركه وكل ما الشركه دفعت لك جزء من
ايراداتها تقل حصتك من الشركه الين ما انك
تستغني عن الحصه بالكامل او تبقى حصه
قليله جدا مقارنه
يعني جولات التمويل المعروفه اللي في
العاده يعني تقضي على 20% او اكثر حتى من
من حصص الشركه فنيا هي خيار للشراء خيار
للشراء حصتك مره اخرى على الورق
اللي يبغى يقوقلها هي
وكنت اتكلم احسان جواد مره ثانيه لانه
الموضوع هذا اللي سمعناه في توتال جراث
اللي طلع من اس تي في واعلن تكلمنا عنه
الحلقه الماضيه وسالته عن تنامي فقال هم
قاعدين يستخدمون نفس التصميم اللي طلعوا
فيه في توتال جروس وايضا يعني يعتبر يصنف
على انه
لعله يعني واحده من الادوات اللي فعلا
مفيده لانه في كثير من الحالات اللي
لاقراض الجريء ولا راس مال الجريء مناسبه
لك يعني مثلا لما اتكلم عن شركات اللي
تعمل الجيمنج مثلا الالعاب الالكترونيه
خلاص صار واضح مؤشرات النمو حقتها
ويحتاج احيانا القرض على مد مده قصيره
وبسرعه
لدينا الجريء ولا الاستثمار رسما الجليب
الملكيه تاخذ اشهر الين يعني تتفقون
وتوصلك الفلوس هنا تجيك بشكل سريع ايضا
لها مزايا اخرى يمكن
تتكلمون عنها بس انا بالنسبه لي السرعه
واحده من المزايا الرئيسيه لكن بالمقابل
لها حالات استعمال يعني
او بديل لراس المال الجري هي خيار اخر
يغطي بعض الحالات اللي ما يعني ممكن
يغطيها الادوات الاخرى بشكل جيد عاد هذا
يذكرني في عام 2019
كنت يعني اقرا وشفت
نموذج جديد او نموذجين جديدين من عالم
الصناديق الاستثمار الجريء اولهم كان
لصندوق كان يقول احنا نؤمن انه لازم تكون
عوائد الصندوق محدوده بحيث انه نقدر نكون
اكثر جاذبيه لرواد الاعمال فكانوا يقولون
ما اذكر هي كانت يا خمسه مضاعفات او عشر
مضاعفات بعد ما انه ترجع خمسه او عشر
مضاعفات لصندوق فهم يتنازلون بالكامل عن
حصتهم حتى لو الشركه وصلت الى مواصيل اكثر
من ذلك صراحه ما ادري وش صار عليهم
ما اتوقع
كانوا يقولون الى ثلاث اضعاف لكن قفلوا
قفل
واضح صاروا صاروا مغرين للمؤسسين لكن مو
مغرين
للمستثمرين حقيناهم
وكاننا نعيش وقت ما كان في فائده عاليه
فبالتالي كان الناس تقول ما نحتاج حاجه زي
كذا اذا احنا وصلنا خلاص يعني المبلغ هذا
كله بيلغي الموضوع عاد الان اللي وراء
عندي في سي قالوا ترى
بنموذج محور شوي ما تغير الماكرو وبنحاول
مره اخرى في في الموضوع بس فكرته يعني
اتوقع بتغير نسبه المخاطر كامله في
الصندوق لانه بالعاده الصندوق الاستثمار
راس مال الجريء يقول لك انا استثمر في
الشركات ويمكن واحده ترجع لي الصندوق كامل
من الاستثمارات فاذا بتحط يعني تفكر فيها
تاخذ البيانات التاريخيه افضل الصناديق
مضاعفين ونص ترجع للمستثمرين فاذا انت كل
صفقه اذا وصلت ثلاث اضعاف تطلع منها وتعطي
الباقي الارباح فيعني الضغط اللي تحطه على
اختيارك لكل استثمار
مهول لازم تكون واثقه جدا
ما تغامر وهو هذا كان تطروحه
في السنه الواحده الا 12 15 يعني او شركه
ملياريه طيب مين اللي يستثمر بالشركات
اللي تجي بعدها واللي بعدها
فكانوا هم يعني
المستوى الثاني والثالث من الشركات اللي
قد لا تصير يعني وتغير السوق اللي حولها
لكن فيها جدوى معينه فكانت على الاقل هذه
الاطروحه اللي يستخدمونها وقتها التجربه
الثانيه اللي طلعت عليها كانت لي سويت
اكوتي
واللي اسمهم قد يشرح وش تسوون بالضبط يعني
من فكره السويتيه او
عرق الزبونه
ههه
والعجيب ان هذول يستثمر معاهم من مؤسس
ليجن سيكون معاهم 26 مليون دولار فكرتهم
انهم صندوق اسماء الجري لكن بدل ما يستثمر
كاش معاك وفعلا احد المؤسس للصندوق هو كان
يعمل في صندوق
واللي هو
يعني شريك فيه فكرتهم انه بدل ما اعطيك
فلوس انا اعطيك جهدي يعني لما نتكلم عن
الصناديق اللي دائما تقول انا اعطيك قيمه
مضافه هذا الصندوق قائم فقط على ما راح
يعطيك ما راح يعطيك ولد ولار راح يعطيك
قيمه مضافه فعندهم يعني اللي هم شركاء
اللي في الصندوق واحد متخصص في التوظيف
واحد متخصص في البرمجه واحد متخصص في الاي
اي
وهكذا فكلهم متخصصين فلما يروحون عند
الشركه يشوفون وش النواقص اللي عندهم وش
الاشياء اللي يحتاجون مساعده وهم يدخلون
يعملون داخل الشركه احيانا الى سته اشهر
12 شهر الين ما يقدرون يوصلون الى
الهدف المتفق عليه وبالتالي تنتقل الاسهم
للصندوق انا صراحه هذه من التجارب اللي
جدا جدا متحمسه شوف نتائجها صندوق عمره
تقريبا ثلاث سنوات فلسه بدري شوي لكن شفت
الشركات اللي عندهم في المحفظه يعني مثيره
جدا الاهتمام كودا
لينك 8 سليب حقت النوم يعني في شركات
صراحه ما هي بسهله ويبدو انها في طريقها
يضيفون يزيدون مركزهم قصدك الثلاثين مليون
اللي جمعوها هم اتوقع رواتب عبد الله
اللي انت تجيب الفكره هم يعني يعطونك
الموارد اللي تساعدك انك تكمل سواء كانت
تقنيه ولا في تطوير المنتج او التسويق له
او غيره يمكن حاجه تسويقه يمكن لا في شيء
فعلا يفرقها عن الاستديو بس هذا السؤال
اللي على قبالي لكن كل الاحوال
بالذات علشان فيها ويريد يعني معروف في
نجاحات وانه متسلسله شوفوا هذه تجربه
تستحق المتابعه احنا ذكرنا عندي وحده ايضا
من الاشياء اللي عملوها عندي حطوا دليل
اسمه انترو انترو في كل انواع التمويل
والبدائل اللي ممكن يفكر فيها المؤسس من
الاشياء اللي احنا تكلمنا عنها ويمكن عشره
12 اخرى اكثر من كذا
فبالتالي يجيب لك اهميه انه يكون في ثقافه
ماليه عند المؤسس او على الاقل يعرف ناس
فاهمين في الفاينانس وفي هيكل الماليه
اللي يقدرون يساعدونك تختار وش الطريقه
الصحيحه للتمويل لكل حاله من الحالات لانه
احيانا تحتاج مزيج من الانواع هذه على حسب
الوضع والحاله اللي انت فيها احنا تكلمنا
عن
جوله تمويليه من خلال مشاركه الدخل لشركه
واحد المستثمرين في يقات اجفت اللي هو
صندوق ام اي في بي ايضا حصل على جوله
تمويليه لكن هالمره من
صندوق الاستثمار الاوروبي بقيمه 27 مليون
دولار من اصل صندوقهم البالغ قيمته 150
مليون دولار فالف مبروك لوليد ولا فريقه
صراحه انجاز لطيف انك تقدر
يعني تجلب اموال عالميه للمنطقه بحيث انها
تستثمر فيه المنشات اللي في المنطقه لهم
موقع خاص في منظومه روس الاموال الاجريه
في المنطقه الواحده من اقدمها عمر الصندوق
تقريبا اكثر من 12 سنه الان لما طلع فيه
وليد حنا واجمالي الاصول اللي موجود عندهم
حسب موقعهم ما ادري عاد فولو للصندوق
الجديد لسه مليون دولار هذا الايون
والجدير بالذكر انه ايضا العبار قبل كذا
سنه داخل معاهم كشريك داخل الصندوق اللي
يسمونه جي بي لكن بدون
تحكم في حصه صامته داخل
الصندوق الجهه الاداريه من الصندوق فكانت
هذه ايضا ملفته الصندوق اللي قاعدين
يجمعونه بحسب الخبر او صندوقهم الرابع
قيمه الكليه 150 مليون دولار وصندوق
الاستثمار الاوروبي استثمر 27 مليون دولار
حول الخمس
لكن كان في تركيز كبير في التصريح وفي
الخبر على الجانب الاثر الاقتصادي وخلق
الوظائف
وحتى كان الكلام في مصر واضافه باكستان
الشرق الاوسط
فباثار فضولي صراحه هذا الموضوع ورحت موقع
ام بي في بي شفتهم كذلك يبدو من زمان
حاطين على الاثر اللي هم يسوونه مو
الاستثمارات وكاتبين كيف كثير من الوظائف
اللي كونتها شركاتهم خدمه او كانت لعوائل
من داخل متوسط ومنخفض وكيف حسنت من مستوى
المعيشه هناك بشكل غير مباشر وكيف التسهيل
الوصول كذلك
او تمكين المراه كانوا حاطينه بشكل مفصول
عدد الفنانات في انغامي مقارنه بالفنانين
فيبدو انه في توافق كذلك في
الجانب الاثر بشكل كبير مو بس انه تمويل
من صندوق الاستثمار الاوروبي لصندوق في
المنطقه طبعا من اللطيف ايضا انه
ايضا مستثمرين في هلا اللي تكلمنا عنها
وايضا مستثمرين في امنتي حالا اللي تكلمنا
عنها قبل حلقتين
وايضا في
انغامي ورين ونعناع وفيهم ايضا عندهم شركه
من الشركات المتميزه اللي اسمها
واللي اعتقد بتكون يعني احد قصص النجاح
يعني في المنظومه في المستقبل القريب لانه
ما شاء الله عليهم بيقدروا يوصلوا لاكثر
من 70 80 دوله فيبدو انه ما شاء الله
المحفظه عندهم المحزم مليان يعني ههه
[موسيقى]
جوله ثانيه نتكلم عنها من السلسله
الفراز الف بسته مليون دولار لشركه تلقاني
تلقاني شفنا مستثمر جذبت مستثمرين
استراتيجيين علم على اوتو كذلك رئيس
تنفيذي شركه الفرسان
انا شفته مدير الاهتمام من الجوله الف لكن
كذلك شركه لها طموح كبير واضح انه
شايفينها لها امل كبير في برنامج شركات
الميلاديه اللي يعلن في ليب تمت دعوتها
كذلك مدري كيف شفت الخبر وش رايكم في
تلقاني نفسه معاليه الفهد المؤسس الشريك
في الشركه هو عبد الملك المكنسي ما له
علاقه زي حقتكم يا عبد الله لكن ما شاء
الله الشباب يعني من الريل هاسلارز اللي
بدايه يعني وقت وقت صعب ايام كوفيد ايضا
في في مجال زي كذا واتكلم عن
استراتيجياتهم في تغيير تج من ناحيه مثلا
يسوون اشياء ما كانت ممكنه قبل كذا سنه
باستخدام رقمنه باستخدام مثلا مفهوم
المراكز او المستودعات السحابيه بحيث انه
السياره تجي العميل بشكل اسرع
في جهد واضح انه اعاده تعريف الحلول
التنقل لكن بالنسبه لي ايضا في لسه اسئله
كبيره على المجال هذا انه هل المستقبل هو
ان سوق سيارات او
الروبوتاكسي كيف يعني بيتقاطع مع شركه زي
كذا علما انه لما طلعت
المجال هذا اللي هو ايجار السيارات استحوذ
على تقريبا مليار ونص مليون دولار للشركات
اللي لسه في
في السوق الخاص اللي لسه ما تم يعني
خروجها
فبالتالي واضح انه في شهيه كبيره بالسوق
لاعاده تعريف هذه فئه من الخدمات طبعا
يعني تلقاني تساعد الافراد ويمكن حتى
الشركات انهم يستاج اختيارات
وفي شركات منافسه كثير في المنطقه سواء
المنافسين مباشرين او غير مباشرين مباشرين
عندك مثلا
الشركه اللي موجوده في الامارات واللي
جمعت قبل اربع شهور او ثلاثه شهور عشره
مليون دولار في جولتهم من طراز
وكثير من الشركات اصلا بدات تتوجه وحتى
تلقاها في موقع تلقاني الى فكره اللي هو
الاشتراك الشهري يعني في ناس عندهم وجهه
نظر قد لا اتفق معها يقول لك ان فكره
امتلاك السياره هي فكره زائله وفعليا ما
تحتاج تتملك السياره لاسباب كثيره من
بينها تكاليف امتلاك السياره وغيرها
فعندهم اطروحه انه بدل ما تتملك السياره
تشترك اشتراك شهري في سياره وبالتالي تقدر
تبدلها مثل ما بغيت وشفنا حتى الشركات مثل
بورشه ومثل مرسيدس سووا برامج مثل سواء في
اوروبا او في امريكا حتى للسيارات الفارهه
وطبعا عندك مخيم ثاني اللي يقول لك لا يا
حبيبي السياره اصلا انت ما تحتاجها الا في
مشوارك فشفنا شركات مثل
ما تحضرني اسمائها بس هي الشركات التي
تستاجر السياره بالمشوار واللي تلقى
السياره مثلا ايجار مثلا وغيرها ويود
درايف صحيح وفي شركات يعني حتى ادت اداء
جيد يعني في اوروبا انا صراحه من الناس
المتشائمين شوي تجاه هذا القطاع بشكل عام
يعني انا اشوف انه في المنطقه عندنا
التخطيط العمراني للمدن مختلف تماما عن
مثلا المدن الاوروبيه القديمه واللي فعلا
صعب امتلاك سياره فيها بسبب عدم وجود
اماكن
للوقوف وغلاء او وجود الكثير من الضرائب
الغاليه هل ممكن الوضع عندنا يستمر مثل ما
هو ليس بالضروره لكن اشوف انه
يعني لابد انك تتملك سياره في في المنطقه
عندنا بغض النظر طبعا هم يستهدفون ايضا
قطاع السياحه سوق واعد خصوصا في المملكه
لانه احنا مقبلين على
مضاعفات لاعداد السياح في في المملكه
فالله يوفقهم صراحه انجاز مو بسهل تكفيره
الجوله الف في الاوضاع هذه الله يوفقهم
على سيره قطاع السياحه في خبر كبير صار في
السوق العالمي جدا كبير ملفت وشركه يبدو
انها تعشق الازمات ار بي ام يعني طلعت في
خضم الازمه الماليه العالميه 2008 وبعدين
جاء كوفيد وبعدها سنتين الان يعلنون انهم
حققوا اول سنه رابحه في تاريخ الشركه وربح
مو بالغلط يعني ربح واحد فاصله تسعه مليار
دولار يعني بس يعني تشوف نموها او تحسين
حقها ما كان بس تحسين تكاليف كان تح كذلك
نمو اضافت 900 الف وحده خارج الصين وصل
عدد الوحدات 6.6 مليون
الهامش التشغيلي 23% وتشوف كثير مقارناتهم
بالنمو في الايرادات حتى مقربه 2019 ما
قبل الجائحه فيعني تحس ان
انطلقوا بشكل كبير اتذكر موضوع
الاستيكيشنز اللي اجازات في نفس البلد
اللي اطلقوه خصوصا في ايام كوفيد وما
بعدها فيبدو ان شركه صححت اشياء كثيره
او انها بنت على حماس الناس للسفر بعد
لكن انا اتصور انه حتى لو بنت على هذا
الحماس كثير من الناس جربوا ار بي ام بي
والان صعب يرجعون الفنادق انا سفيري في
هذا الشيء كان معاذ في واحده من السفرات
اصر اننا نجرب ار بي ام بي وفعلا اول ما
كانت لكن تشوف المدينه اللي تزورها بزاويه
جدا مختلفه لما تسكن في اربي ام بي
يعني هذه من الشركات العزيزه جدا على قلبي
واللي يمكن استخدمها من عام 2012 انا ما
اذكر اني سافرت من 2012 الى اليوم ورحت
طواعيه وحجزت اوتيل فشركه لها اثر كبير
على حياتي احبها جدا وساعدت جدا صراحه
بالخبر ويعني يعني قاعدين نشوف القطاع
بشكل عام كله قاعد يستعيد عافيته خصوصا في
عام 2022
يبدو
[موسيقى]
ترى لا تتفاعلون نعم
بس ترى شركه ما هي بسهله يعني نتكلم على
88 88 مليار دولار هو القيمه السوقيه
للشركه يعني ما نتكلم عن شركه صغيره 400
مليون ليله تم حجزها في عام 2022
يعني ترى ارقام يعني مهوله مهوله جدا نسبه
نمو حول الخمسين في المئه على هذا الحجم
من الدخل سته فاصله سته مليون منزل مضاف
في المنصه يعني ارقام صراحه مخيفه مخيفه
جدا وانا ابغى استغل الفرصه هذه علشان ادق
في خرافه عند كثير من المستثمرين بخصوص
المؤسسين انه لازم واحد منهم يكون تقني
هنا جو براين كلهم غير تقنيين مصممين
قدروا يبنون منصه ناجحه في الاقتصاد
التشاركي يمكن واحده من انجح المنصات الان
فهذه يعني دليل انه عالم البي سي هو عالم
البحث عن الاستثناءات وليس انك تحط قالب
وتركب الشركات على القالب هذا وشركه 100
ملي دولار يعني في فتره من فترات وصل
تقييمها الى 100 مليار فيعني اللي هو
النتيجه العظمى اللي يبحث عنها اي مستثمر
يعني فعلا ما في ما في ولكن في حاجه واحده
ما ادري انت حاسس فيها ولا لا لانه انت
يعني عندك حريه مين موجوده عندي انا
عندي اطفال اخاف في سمعه سيئه طلعت الان
الار بي ام بي بخصوص
الرسوم الخفيه بخصوص حتى بدي ينكتون عليها
انه بيشغلني انظف وراء
صاحب الشقه واغسل الصحون واشيل الزباله
وشيء الاخر للغائات اللي تصير مفاجاه فلو
انا شخص مثلا رايح لحالي انا سويتها مثلا
في البزنس احب اسوي لكن اذا معي اسره
ومخططين اجازه يعني كبيره اخاف جدا اني
اروح اير بي ام بي حقيقه وجربوا هم الان
تجربه وقال في اعلانه الاخير انه يبدو
انها التجربه هذه بدات تاتي ثمارها انه
يبين لك كل الرسوم مقدما طبعا لها عيب
كبير انه المنصات الاخرى ما تسوي الشيء
هذا فبالتالي اذا انت ما انت عارف ان اربي
ان بي تسوي الشيء هذا والباقين لا قد تبدو
لك الوحدات اللي موجوده على البي ام بي
اغلى من غيرهم فلتروح للمنافسين هو يقول
لا الى الان ما شفنا الجانب السيئ فاي
حساب لهم انا قرروا الناس اللي طبعا هو
للاسف فعلا يعني من خلال تجارب الكثيره في
يعني يعني هوستس او الناس اللي هم
يستضيفون الناس في بيوتهم او في شققهم
فعلا عندهم تطلبات غير منطقيه يعني اذكر
مره في مدينه ميونخ حجزت وانا في المطار
بعد ما وصلت الطياره
عندهم خاصيه انك تقدر تحجز البيت من غير
موافقه صاحب البيت بمعنى انه
يتم القبول بشكل تلقائي
فبعدين في
الريفيو حقي صاحب البيت او صاحبه البيت
كتبت انه معاذ من اسوا الناس اللي مروا
علينا تخيلوا انه تخيلوا انه حجز قبل
اربعين دقيقه من وصوله طيب يا اخي انت
مفعل الخاصيه يعني وفعلا اعطتني تقييم
نجمه وهذا تقييم لاحقني الى اليوم يعني في
ناس يقولون شفنا البروفايل حقك كل شيء
تمام الا هذا التقييم واضح انك راعي مشاكل
يعني
وش سويت
في صفه واحده
وهذي الناس يكتشفون بطريقه الصعبه انه
المنصه تفضل المضيف على الضيف المضيف هو
بالنسبه لهم العميل الحقيقي هو اللي درنهم
تدخل هذا فعاده صار في اشكاليه الافضليه
للمضيف والان يحاولون يوازنها شوي نشوف في
نقطه اخرى يمكن تساعدك معاد بمستقبلا
مساعدنا احنا سؤال ههه سؤال بدا يكرر في
كل
الاجتماعات اللي يعملون الراسات الماليه
في تقرير ربعيه الماليه حقتهم مع المحللين
اللي هو يعني وش موقفك من موضوع ذكاء
الصناعي
واخواتها اللي قاعدين يطلعون هل هذه
معناها بكره انه اقدر القى الشقه اللي
ابغاها بدون ما اجي الاير بي ام بي لانه
يروح يتكلم ويحاور ويفاوض ويجيب لي الشقه
الافضل ولا لا وقال شيء جميل صراحه قال لا
بالعكس احنا ما نفكر انك تلقى الوحده حقتك
على انها عمليه بحث هي المفروض ان عمليه
مواءمه احنا نبغى نصنع تجربه فالذكاء
الصناعي بيساعدنا على الموائمه بشكل ما
كنا قادرين عليه قبل وحنا افهم بالموضوع
هذا من غيرنا فهذه ايضا نقطه جميله تستحق
المتابعه خلال سنه تجاريه انه استراتيجيه
كيف تتغير محاوله منافسه في القطاع طبعا
يمكن الشق المحلي من هذا الخبر هو يعني
وجود منصه محليه فعليا قاعده تقدم خدمه
مشابهه وبتميز او بعمق محلي واللي هي
قادرين خصوصا بعد حصولهم على رخصه قبل
فتره وبعد يعني اطلاق العديد من التشريعات
اللي قاعده تساعد وتسرع من عمليه تكبير
هذا السوق يعني لو ترجعون قبل خمس سنوات
حتى ار بي ام بي ما كان له اي تواجد حقيقي
في المملكه يعني قادرين وجود لاعب محلي
قاعد يدفع العجله وقاعد يعمل مع المشرعين
بحيث انه يصير في تشريعات واضحه اليوم لو
تدخل سواء الاستراحات ولا الشقق ولا حتى
في المناطق النائيه مثل الجنوب والعلا
وغيره تلقى خيارات كثيره فلعل هذا يعني
الخبر الايجابي من بي يعود بالنفع على
جادرن بشكل او باخر من خلال اثبات كفاءه
يعني النموذج هذا احنا نتكلم عن شركه ترى
بدات في 2008 وصلت الربحيه 2023 او 22
فتره طويله
وهذا يذكرني ايضا باوبر اللي لسه ما زالوا
يعني بداوا عاد اوبر شوي بعد بس ما زالوا
الى الحين خسائرهم متلتله لكن كثير من هذه
النماذج اللي كان حولها اسئله بدات الان
تثمر
يعني نتمنى لي قادر ان شاء الله كل
التوفيق فرصه فرصه للاشاده بمؤسسين قادر
ان ايمان السويلم ولطيفه التميمي جهه جبار
ما شاء الله الله يعطيهم العافيه طيب عبد
الله وليد هل في عندكم ايه اقتراحات
لاشياء يعني ممتعه مرت عليكم انا يمكن
ابدا بذكرت المحللين ابو عبد العزيز شفت
مقطع شرح جميل
لشركه ابحاث صغيره جدا اسمها شركه هندر
بورد الابحاث اعتقد انه اسمهم صحيح سووا
التحليل على واحده من اكبر المجموعات
التجاريه في الهند
من امريكا
بس اطلقوا التقرير يقول لك غير منطقي
الارقام اللي قاعده تقولها هذه المجموعه
ولعل هذا التقرير اخذ يعني مجراه مستقل
بدت الناس
تسال اسئله اضافيه للشريء المجموعه
والشركات بدات الاسهم تنخفض المالك كان
احد اغنى الناس في العالم بدا ينزل حتى
ثروته المقدره
عجبني الشرح وعجبني المبدا نفسه انه مع
كثره وجود المحللين لكن الواحد اللي يقعد
ويسوي تحليل الخاص ممكن يلقى زوايا جديده
فممكن نضع الرابط في في الحلقه كمان على
سيره الزوايا اللي انا انصح فيها واقترحه
هي مقابله
تنفرسلي اسطوره في عالم راس مال الجيري
واحد من الشركاء في بنش مارك الصندوق ايضا
اسطوري ومعروف
يعني بالنسبه لي يعني في نوع من التعاطف
معاه لانه تخصصه ايضا علوم حاسب ودخل عالم
الاستثمار فكان يتكلم مع التم فيروس عن
تاريخه عن رحلته وكيف هو بدا بنيوزلترز
لما كانت وقتها الفاكس وكيف قدر يحصل يعني
يحصل سواء كيف قدر يحصل على الاسماك ويحكي
تاريخ كثير والرجال مقبل على تقاعد قريب
ورغم ذلك تشوف كميه الطاقه اللي في بركان
متفجر ونوعيه الافكار اللي قاعد يطلع فيها
للمستقبل شخص صراحه يعني يبعث على
زياده الهمه والعزيمه اللي كنا نتكلم عنها
في البدايه انا من عندي صراحه ودي انصح
بمشاهده لقاء او يعني جلسه
جمعت صندوق اندريس
وادم نومن مؤسس ويورك سابقا ومؤسس فلو
حاليا لو تذكرون الخبر حق استثمار اندريسن
350 مليون دولار في فلو وكان في علامات
استفهام كثيره حول كيف انهم راحوا لادم
نؤمن يبدو انه يعني الضغط عليهم كان عالي
جدا لدرس انهم اضطروا يسوون جلسه عامه
مصوره مع ادم فعليا مارك ان جالس يشرح ليش
استثمروا مع ادم وليش ادم هو ريادي ممتاز
وليش هذه الفرصه فرصه ممتازه كنوع يعني
يعني مجابهه التغطيه السلبيه اللي حصلوا
عليها فصراحه شيء لطيف خمسين دقيقه لا
طبعا
موجود يمكن شافوا ايش صار للسكويا
معها بعض المستثمرين ضد سكويا ضد المسلمين
الاخرين اللي استثمروا فيه اف تي اكس
فلعلى حركه استباقيه انه ترى يا جماعه
خلونا نشرح لكم ترى في فكره
ههه
بالضبط بس طبعا يعني بلا شك انه قصه ادم
يعني تستحق المتابعه
ويبدو انه ناوي على نيه عاد ينجح ما ينجح
موضوع ثاني لكن يبدو انه ناوي على شيء
كبير عبد الله وليد كالعاده
جلسه لا يؤمن منها اشوفكم الاسبوع القادم
ان شاء الله يعطيكم العافيه شكرا لكم
وشكرا لفريق بودكاست السوق في اداره
الانتاج اصيل بافرط وفي التحرير عاد عيسى
وفي الهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز المزي بين
مساهم في التصوير كل من ياسر بن غانم وهاب
موسى واحمد طالب وساعد في التصوير ياسر
السوق احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع
[موسيقى]